hi there steve kaufman here it's a rainy
friday afternoon in uh vancouver
i played my old-timers hockey this
morning
and uh feeling good
and i'm i must say i'm getting a
tremendous kick out of all of the venom
that i have stirred up in the
uh linguistics community at least
amongst those who have come to comment
uh on my recent video where i talked
about the joy
of being a linguist and the power
of
input-based learning
and so people just keep on coming back
and saying you can't use the word
linguist to mean someone who speaks many
languages
and i say but that's the dictionary
definition that's how the majority of
people understand the word people talk
about
uh accomplished linguists or skilled
linguists they mean people who speak
languages
it says on the dictionary why can't i
use the term that way
ah they come back but the dictionary is
simply reporting on how people use the
word wrongly
in other words the dictionary which
reports on usage and basically
you know tries to explain how words are
used in the language
the dictionary therefore is only
reporting on the fact that the vast
majority of people use the word wrong
there's nothing missing there
words
derive their meaning from how they're
used
and
i just look at this word linguist and i
see that according to wikipedia
which is really not a bad source of
information
the word linguist was first used in 1580
and it meant a master of language one
who uses his tongue freely
in the 1640s it
gained an additional or
was described in different ways as a
student of language but they didn't have
linguistics in those days
to understand what linguistics is
then again i went to wikipedia and i
looked up a bunch of stuff there and
of course people like to say i mean
you don't understand linguistics you're
too stupid and stuff like that that's
what they tell me
but i've read books on it i have books
at home
and i now look at this wikipedia entry
and to me
linguistics is not interesting at all
has nothing to do with language learning
nothing and there's a lot of
sophisticated
um
i call it pseudo science there
uh
at least that's my reaction to it
and i've expressed myself on this idea
that we have some universal grammar
built into us no i don't believe that i
think the brain just is very good at
developing patterns or seeing patterns
in the in the
range of experience that it's confronted
with because it has to do that in order
that it can then take advantage of the
previous experience to to learn new
things
so um
so you know what's the what's the
concern here uh yes there is this other
word polyglot which means the same thing
most english speakers have never heard
the word polyglot but they have heard
the word linguist
steve is quite the linguist he speaks
more than one language
in the year
2003 i wrote a book
called the linguist a personal guide to
language learning and we started our
first website
for
you know helping people learn english
by and large because of the problem we
saw here with uh immigrants to canada
who couldn't speak english very well and
who weren't very well served by the
classroom model
and we called that site the linguist
and you know and as i look at this book
i mean all the things that i wrote in
2003 there's hardly anything there that
i would have changed i'm s it's still
the same thing uh you have to be
motivated to learn a language uh the
world is full of potential linguists
people who could easily learn to speak
more than one language and who would
derive great enjoyment from it i'm
motivated to i'm an activist i want
there to be more linguists i want i even
want the word linguist which really only
means someone who speaks more than one
language it only has that meaning
apparently in english in all other
languages
the word has been hijacked
by these linguistics people
to mean someone who is a
specialist in the field of linguistics i
would rather see
the word linguist mean what it meant
back in 1580 someone who speaks a number
of languages
and uh everything we do and my
involvement is trying to increase the
number of people who are
linguists in that sense
and in fact
if we take the sort of ist suffix
again i went to wikipedia
and there are a total of 349
words listed on the in the wiktionary
english words suffixed with ist there's
all kinds of them you know activist
guitarist you know there's even a word
hockeyist hockeyist that's someone who
plays hockey
violinist
uh rightist leftist optimist
uh i don't know
uh all kinds of them globalist
um
atheists
uh you know whatever what do we got here
so
there's nothing that says
that the word ist has to apply to your
professional occupation
uh you know we have separatists here in
canada and we have federalists
it can be
your activity your interest your
ideological persuasion
there's even an insulationist here
images denturist apologist
i don't know
ironist somebody who use irony uses
irony
so
perfectly legitimate from uh the point
of view of historical uh etymology from
the point of view of how the word is
used from every possible point of view
uh it's quite logical to use the word
linguist and and the conceit
of of these linguistics uh
people to suggest that the way the word
is used by the vast majority of the
people is wrong
the way the word is used by a very small
number of linguistics specialists is
right
very strange
the point of all of this is
that
first of all and another thing is the
word linguist sounds a lot nicer in
english than polyglot
so i would far rather be a linguist than
a polyglot a linguist in the sense that
i mean linguist
so uh and how do we get to be linguists
read my book
come the link and here again people love
to say well steve was against the
linguist's linguistics or whatever
because he can't make money at it
irrelevant
come up with an argument that says
that
explain why the way the word is used by
the majority people is wrong like why is
it wrong if that's how the majority
people use it words can evolve meaning
the meaning of words can evolve
and i only hope that the word the use of
the word linguist spreads into other
languages
and i always get back to that other part
of my previous
video and that is
the easiest way to become fluent in
another language is to begin with a
major effort on input it's not
complicated just listen and read and
build your vocabulary and that's what
they did in the middle ages and that
gets you to a level where you can
actually understand and so once you've
got
your comprehension up you can understand
you are now in a position to engage
people in conversation to communicate
meaningfully and once that starts to
happen then your language can really
improve of course you need to speak of
course you need to speak a lot to become
a fluent speaker but you first have to
get to the first rung of the ladder and
that first run of the ladder is to
understand and the best way to get there
is through a lot of input-based learning
you have to put in the time you have to
have the attitude you have to believe
you can do it and you have to start
noticing what's happening so again the
elevator
uh
speech or whatever the simple thing
about language learning is learn the
words and phrases learn what they mean
learn how they sound and then take it
from there and become a linguist
thank you for listening